En fait il y a des petits trucs que les gens font quand ils téléphonent
qui me stresse par exemple les gens qui prennent pas la même voix dans la vraie vie et au téléphone
"Matteo, combien de fois je vais te dire de ranger ta putain de chambre bordel de merde ?"
"Oui allô bonjour j'aimerais prendre rendez vous avec ma bancaire s'il vous plaît, Isabelle Pichtouille."
Ce mec qui t'appelle mais t'as l'impression que c'est toi qui le dérange
"Allô ? Allô ? ça va ? Ouais écoute j'ai pas trop le temps là, je suis un peu dans le rush on se rappelle un peu plus tard"
"Ok." // Ou alors les gens qui parlent pendant un siècle,
impossible de les stopper, alors toi pour amorcer leur raccrochage tu lâches des petits...
"Allez... Yes... D'accord...On fait comme ça..."
"Ta gueule ! Ta gueule Maintenant ! T'arrête de parler voilà! Je t'aime." // Le mec qui est sur son phone quand tu l'appelles et qui du coup
décroche super vite il n'y a même pas de bip. "Alors, Anthony... -Allô?
Comment tu as fait pour décrocher si vite? Car je te suis depuis toujours... HAHAHAHA
Je rigole, j'ai pas peur. Je sais très bien que c'est moi en fait. C'est un effet spécial. Regarde. Hop, haha!"
Des fois au téléphone, quand tu raccroches, chacun a ses petits tocs tu vois, ses petites manies...
Par exemple, il y a ceux qui se mettent à chuchoter pour dire aurevoir  :
*rire malaisée*
Ok on fait comme ça. Vas-y à demain. Ciao.
*chuchote*
Bye. Ciao. Bye-Bye. Yes, ciao.
"Qui veut une bière ?" // Et puis des fois t'as des petits réflexes en raccrochant que tu regrettes après. // "Merci, bisous."
*musique dramatique*
"Allô patron, ouais j'ai raccroché en disant bisous mais c'est pas que je voulais dire... C'est... D'accord, pas de problèmes.
Merci à demain. Bisous."
*musique dramatique*
Les gens qui te disent bonjour mais via quelqu'un d'autre au téléphone. Ça donne le dialogue le plus nul du monde. -Bah il est là
attends, je lui dis
-Sylvie te dit bonjour
-Bah, dit lui bonjour de ma part. -Il te répond bonjour,
Elle te demande si ça va ?
-Bah tu sais quoi, passe la moi directement parce que là c'est super chiant en fait.
Quand quelqu'un se trompe de numéro et qu'il n'arrive pas à comprendre qu'il s'est trompé.
-Allô Jacqueline ?
-Ah non... -C'est pô Jacqueline ? -Je pense que vous avez composé un mauvais numéro là...
-Bah...
-Elle est où Jacqueline ? -Et bien je ne sais pas où elle est puisque c'est un mauvais numéro donc je n'ai pas de rapports avec Jacqueline.
Et ce qui est génial c'est que là souvent le mec au bout de deux minutes recompose le même mauvais numéro... -Allô Jacqueline ?
*Soupir*
- C'est ça c'est Jacqueline. Ouais. Tu passes une bonne journée? Tu t'es chié dessus combien de fois aujourd'hui ?
Quand on est au téléphone, je sais pas pourquoi on fait plein de trucs un peu débiles. Déjà quand ça capte mal,
on dirait que les deux personnes elles font une battle de barres de réseaux. // -Allô, putain mec tu captes pas là moi j'ai deux barres
de réseau, hein.
-Alors ça ça m'étonnerait parce que là j'ai trois barre de réseaux donc... -Eh ben moi je suis chez Bouygues,
et ici ça capte tout le temps normalement donc c'est vraiment toi c'est sûr. -Ah ouais ben moi j'ai moi j'ai pas une petite bite...
*Malaise*
-Désolé j'avais pas d'arguments... // Bien sûr la fameuse technique de pas décrocher tout de suite pour faire style t'es occupé.
*sonnerie d'iPhone*
*musique sensuelle*
*rire*
-Yes j'arrive, j'arrive les gars. Allô?
-Allo?...
-Ah merde... Trop tard.
Moi j'avoue au téléphone, comme la personne ne me voit pas
je suis toujours tenté de mentir un peu  // -Allô, ouais je suis en chemin là je suis dans la rue j'arrive. - T'es dans la rue?
Ouais ouais c'est une rue sans voiture et sans passants.
*Miaulement*
-Avec mon chat qui miaule. // Quand tu rappelles un numéro que tu connais pas et la personne n'ose pas dire qui elle est alors qu'elle viens de
t'appeler, c'est tellement absurde.. // -Oui bonjour ,vous m'avez appellé... - Ouais mais c'est qui ?- Ah bah non, c'est vous qui m'appelé donc toi t'es qui ?
-Non toi t'es qui d'abord ? - Ben non moi je dis pas toi t'es qui ? -Bon ok moi c'est Adolf Hitler.
Ah... *rire* Comment il va? // Quand tu téléphones et que tout à coup tu te mets à marcher nerveusement partout chez toi. // -Ouais.
-Sérieux?
-D'accord, c'est pas vrai... Allez! Attends quitte pas juste deux secondes, je bois un peu d'eau parce que là j'en peux plus... J'ai fait dix kilomètres.
Et je peux pas finir sans parler des répondeurs. J'en ai marre d'entendre tout le temps le même genre de répondeur.
-Bonjour, vous êtes bien sur le téléphone de Pierre Nicolas
vous pouvez me laisser un message après le bip. Je dis exactement ce qu'il faut dire sur un message répondeur.
-Allô ? Et non t'es sur mon répondeur. HAHAHAH
-Thibault Blanchard
-Bonjour je suis en déplacements pros à New York.
"Arrivé du T.E.R à Roubaix." -Ah merde, comment on raccroche ?
-Bonjour. laissez-moi un message après le bip. -Hello, leave me a message after the BIP
-Je vous rappelle que je possède le teufel. -Let me remind you that I got the «teufel».
«BIP» «BEP»
-Bonjour, vous êtes bien sur le répondeur de Norman. -Merci de vous abonner après le bip sonore. -Merci aussi d'avoir regardé cette vidéo,
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu et on se retrouve j'espère après le cap des 10 millions d'abonnés youtube ! Ciao!
*BIP*
Sous-titres par Zaarow.